saluta tamarro stasera c'è martin garics
e blogger o ovviamente lorenzo mi ha
portato dei pacchi è arrivato questo
palco mi ha detto inizia a registrare
che devo fare dato reaction in diretta
lo sta aprendo in diretta io non ho idea
di che cosa ci sia dentro
no non è vero
no non è vero se stessa ma la pizza di
martin gas i ragazzi a scherzando spesa
da messi esulta avere un cartone della
pizza 4
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora siccome non ho registrato la parte
in cui ho incontrato garics perché non
mi va di andare lì con la videocamera
non voglio kagarlik benedetto questo la
foto che abbiamo fatto è stata la
seguente quella che anche nella
copertina del video dove lui mi fa il
ciò picciotti la cosa strana che io non
gli ho chiesto di fare casino ha fatto
lui
ok la particolarità di tutto questo è
che se guardate la scatola della pizza
me la sono fatta firmare e nell emozione
del momento ho afferrato la scatola e ho
sparato col dito completamente la parola
pizza rovinando così metà scatola
fantastico grande fa dj come ormai è
abituato non ci vediamo una brutta fare
più bella grossa la dedica e ci è stato
talmente tanto che è una certa gli
volevano proprio dire se bild tranquilli
non è che mi dava un poema ci siamo
parlati mi ha fatto un po delle domande
e gli ho detto mi sono trasferito da
poco e allora la dedica sulla pizza è
stata hubert nei giochi ora musica o su
wikis amazing pizza sbavato pizza perché
sono scemo che sarebbe
va meglio a goderti questa fantastica
casa con questa fantastica pizza sempre
e comunque sbavatura di pizza parte
continuiamo pure con il log giorno
successivo aspetta che voglio vedere dal
suo reaction appena farò così
this is for you my man si pensa che
mette aeroporto ha pensato che io lo
portassi a una ragazza ti piace la rosa
1 dipinto è infatti come me sai che
diventerò commenti coi capelli tra un po
si
spero anche con la barba bene la
partenza è quella giusta effetto
promette tutto benissimo perché sono un
deluso
siamo pronti tieniti bene zio però
beh veramente che state portando
finalmente
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tanto per cambiare un po abbiamo dei
cambiamenti anche a pietro sugli
intercity italiano abrate
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora dovete seguire ci siete
lo fai dai te b day
che cosa fare non saprei rompiamo il
cazzo a parigi voi usando salvezza non
si dice
si no
[Musica]
vabbè quindi altro inserito al progetto
che bella napoli tre persone sul
motorino senza casco come arrivederci e
grazie
ne vada
credo che la cartella bella ai piatti
dai separatisti
[Musica]
eccoci qua
si accendono c'erano
lo posso fare
[Musica]
queste ore con draka giusto
è tutta la vita che la gente sogna di
vedere di lavorare per adesso detto
mario draghi ha trovato un lavoro vero
sintetizza fa cagare l'ha fatta parigi
bravi ok rago appena finito di montare
questo video che avete appena visto
sono un po sfatto perché e vabbè fatto
un raduno di 26 ore però tutto a posto
volevo anche dirvi che siccome adesso ho
cambiato il logo del canale ai prossimi
raduni che farò ci saranno le magliette
nuove con il logo nuovo quindi voglio
qui vedervi con tutte le magliette 9 non
con quelle vecchie anche se quelle
vecchie rimangono comunque [ __ ] ma con
quelle nuove
la [ __ ] arriva prima quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come se il
momento mi piace anche vari stato il
comizio
ci vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]